chou-fleur brocoli courge patate douce
de plus en plus de légumes se transforme
en croûte de pizza
sur les réseaux sociaux les recettes
multiplie est l'une des plus populaires
et à base de chou-fleur
[Musique]
les pizzerias en boîte aussi le pas
plusieurs grande chaîne ajoute ses
crottes de légumes alors menu
sans gluten
et aussi une photo qui fait ça fait
peut-être que c'est venu ça devient de
plus en plus populaire
fonction des nouvelles tendances régime
de quoique ce soit le pain aussi été
accusé de de tous les mots en santé en
alimentation et c'est complètement le
pain et le remplacer par des légumes à
la culture des régimes c'est le c'est de
enlever tous les
c'est vraiment un sens donné une grande
popularité de légumes
[Musique]
tellement populaire Caen épicerie
l'offre de pizza surgelée au fruit de
légumes grandi les pizzas se déclinent
dans une variété de légumes mais aussi
parfois de légumineuses d'amande et un
grand choix de saveur de pizza c'est
vraiment une crotte de chocolat
en compagnie de Stéphanie côté
l'épicerie analyser une trentaine de
pizza surgelée fait à base de croûte de
légumes afin de savoir de quoi ils sont
composés et si elle nous permettre de
faire un meilleur choix
qui a traditionnelle
ça dépend de quelle manière on les
compare les liste d'ingrédients la
croûte à pizza traditionnelle de la
farine de blé de la levure de l'eau ça
peut être quand même assez simple il y a
jamais de fruit à base de légumes qui
est aussi simple que ça prend plus
d'ingrédients donc en ce sens c'est pas
c'est pas gagnant à tout coup d'avoir
une crotte de légumes
mais avons-nous réellement une pension
de légumes en choisissant de tel croûte
c'est le premier bien belle ça commence
à ressembler à des vrai légume qui a
dans notre assiette alors que parfois
les légumes viens
en bonus dans une pâte à pizza à peu
près normal on va dire ça en fait très
variable
[Musique]
20h15. 5e et 8e ou même une pizza
entière difficile de se retrouver avec
les portions du tableau de valeur
nutritive stéphanie a établi les
critères pour une demi pizza une portion
plus réaliste selon elle la grande
majorité des pizzas elles sont trop sali
c'est souvent là où le bât blesse
beaucoup de pizza à croûte de légumes
manque de protéine c'est vraiment ces
deux éléments le fait que
quelque chose à améliorer le son un peu
plus équilibré seulement certaines
il y a aussi des croûtes de légumes pour
faire notre propre pizza
d'avoir une pizza seulement hier soir
ou la liste des ingrédients est la plus
court parce que quand il est plus
d'ingrédients j'ai remarqué que souvent
c'était des invités de
celle que j'ai trouvé le plus
intéressant c'est celle qui avait les
ingrédients le plus proche de les
ingrédients qu'on utilise soi-même donc
la choix du président la bonne et la
colline qui est seulement vraiment
légumes sans gluten et sans pour les
personnes qui ont la maladie celiac
et si on poussait plus loin en faisant
la croûte de légumes maison intéressant
quand on a des allergies des
intolérances ou tout simplement pour
ajouter plus de légumes à son
alimentation comme le fait Andréanne une
pizza aux légumes au chou-fleur que des
choux-fleurs ou presque et certaine et
donc pas de farine au travers c'est
vraiment que des légumes
Andréane et nutritionniste chaque
automne elle fait des réserves de
crucifères pour ces recette de croûte de
pizza l'automne les brocolis et les
choux-fleurs sont tes mains sont en
spécial mais j'aime bien les passer je
t'aime en robot pour les transformer en
semoule Caen j'ai seulement le ça
ressemble vraiment un couscous je suis
jeune était congelé tout simplement
au chou-fleur broyé elle mélange bœuf
fromage herbes de Provence huile et des
graines de lin pour absorber le surplus
d'eau c'est magnifique
ça sent bon ça sent
la bouche
donc on se rappelle
dans la journée puis on voit vraiment
complètement détruit
s'étendre
7 ans mais à la fois un petit
croustillant
comment on aime finalement d'une contact
j'aime comment ça
j'adore la pizza sur une bonne
dans ses vidéos sur les réseaux sociaux
Stéphanie exploit arrêt proposer Lucie
les recettes tout en donnant des
conseils sur la prévention des régime
normal avec une croûte de pain ce n'est
pas bon pour nous c'est
là où j'ai parce que
choisir un maximum de sodium et plus de
15 grammes de protéines pour une pizza
il y a des épinards et
des légumes ça fait pour que ça soit une
pizza
[Musique]
on a besoin de vivre
de manger une bonne pizza sur Crottet
régulière de beaucoup de légumes déçu de
jazz et un peu